well it's a Monday I want to welcome
everybody on this it's a rather cloudy
and temperate day he's here it's hazy
hazy and there's a little bite near its
sweater weather and that's my favorite
time because I can bulk up and look a
little thicker than I normally am it's
beginning to look a lot like Christmas
I know Rishon me I have makeup size was
easy these are in ze yeah we should sing
a couple of Christmas songs we should do
a Christmas album doing so or just the
next episode well you know what I'd like
to do I'd like to do in rendition of
it's cold outside and maybe I'll play
around with the lyrics and that could be
fun yeah it's beginning to look a lot
like Christmas know this line take a
look in the five-and-ten glistening
that's at the height any once again take
a look at tight end
105 tell us dost was a store with candy
canes silver lanes aglow can't hear
they're beginning to look a lot like
Christmas toys in every store this
Johnny Mathis but the prettiest sight
she is the Holly that will be on your
own front door [ __ ] that song bro pair
of Hopalong boots and a pistol that
shoots people in their face is anything
more annoying than people put up
Christmas trees too early yeah you know
what you know what is like a super pet
peeve of mine Christmas colors or
Christmas songs before it's too early
until December hits you shouldn't be
doing any of that
it will Lily drive me nuts like on the
radio like my favorite country station
105.1 switches to all Christmas music
just they don't give you a [ __ ] heads
up or not now I hit two it's Rudolph the
red-nosed reindeer like what the [ __ ]
yeah middle of November yeah [ __ ] you
want to fly star they start early yeah
man I was looking for my [ __ ] tunes
the father my father loves and my wife
loved Christmas dude I love Christmas
too but they're happy it's December 1st
man even then let's not get too crazy
yeah but then you strike in the middle
of this
I think it's Jeremy we had to buy added
by a fake Christmas tree at Home Depot
now now the reason I had to buy a fake
tree is because a real tree will send my
wife into an apoplectic she's she's
Jewish nature [ __ ] to pine you know and
for most of her childhood until she was
like seventeen she would come down with
the worst allergies and they couldn't
figure out what it was what was the tree
in your house was the only December
though yeah well but they start early
they start in like August so anyway I go
to by myself he gives me a she gives me
a picture of the nine-foot fake tree I
have to buy and I'm like iron I go buy a
plastic fake tree yeah order off the
internet yeah
yeah but I go to Home Depot well that
cost me four hundred and seventy dollars
sir yeah brother we cannot say nine-foot
trees dude what do you think looks
really [ __ ] though Wow let's not get
crazy
still a lot of big one too they they
look fake it's a lot of money to dish
out for a five g's no pony no trees you
up your tree in your house Jen no I
don't hold on you're downtown loft The
Bachelor Tara scripts where your parents
are at your parents have one no they
used to do it every year to they don't
do it off to they said [ __ ] yeah some
certain ages go [ __ ] a lot of Korean lot
of Christian Koreans though yeah yeah
but event you might get all your just
[ __ ] it it's just you think about light
I know as a kid I wore my tie put lights
on my dad be on that [ __ ] ladder I'd
be home the lights I guess it took
forever my daughter wanted me I can pay
sone do it my daughter goes it just a
star on the top it's floppy dad don't
have time you get your little ass up
then you get up there you risk your life
it's it's rarely see people with the
real trees though a lot of work that the
[ __ ] bristles fall off everywhere I
like the scent within us throw it out
afterwards my father my mother I like my
trees like I like my tits bro tall and
tight and pointy fake
man that's good I like my trees like I
might might it's fake it's very so good
my dad and I well they decided my mother
said I want a huge tree cuz she always
did so we go get a real tree and the
base of it was a little smaller than
your average redwood was a [ __ ] giant
train Connecticut it's so much work well
it's not only just work then you get
that stand problem with a stand is that
it's not holding a giant tree we got a
tree that was simply too big we had
strapped to the roof our car you're not
God like the Griswold yeah here's the
thing with those stands you have to
drill into that trees [ __ ] base like
you know those weirdos that break their
neck that's where those head breaks that
they screw into their heads uh-huh you
do that to the tree stand that's right
the [ __ ] drill into that goddamn yeah
we didn't know that we didn't do that
and here's the other thing you need to
understand water that [ __ ] there's only
there's one person was less handy than
you old then Oh bride and it's papa kill
him it's my paw and the other thing is
my paw grew up super poor and had to do
a lot of manual labor he's not just so
when when he has to do manual able to
even put a Christmas tree up like the
man of the house he gets he gets it
reminds him when he was poor so he gets
crazy you just mean mean so i'm travina
so we buy this stupid base the tree is
for real the tree is for real like like
probably 200 pounds I don't know it's a
huge tree it's giant so you know they
come wrapped up we on it just goes but
like a [ __ ] like a peacock like what the
[ __ ] is this I'm gonna forest we're
trying to I gotta I have a bowie knife
this giant bowie knife I'm hacking away
with this thing
uh I'm 1718 long story short we try to
put the tree up it's not working it
falls the [ __ ] over three times my
father takes the stand and whips it
whips it like out like a boomerang like
a frisbee yeah
throws it end over end and it hits my
mother's she bought something in China
that cost I don't know how it costs more
than the average human being on the on
the black market sure and it it she's
like she freaks out the tree falls he
tackles the tree hi this is no no
[ __ ] he goes get out of my way my
mother's no get out of my way he tackles
the tree all six four of them
picks it up runs it outside in the yard
keeps running and throws it where this
ravine and throws it into the ravine for
him well it's not our property anymore
isn't Connecticut no Christmas no
grassman is over dude he gets in his car
goes and checks into a hotel my mom and
I dragged the tree back we tie it up
with ropes and now we have a tree with
row it wasn't grade that was our Chris
it's such a hassle man cuz she's a cat
you guys [ __ ] with Christmas trees I
like the way they look but I'd rather go
to the Grove and see it nothing at the
house huh vietnamese they don't exactly
celebrate Saint Nick Saint Nick mrs.
heat goes over Vietnam on a sled in his
he's passed though cake oh man those
guys they don't believe I'll figure it
out may keep gone but you grew up here
so there's like to me
Christmas is no longer really a
religious holiday it's more of just like
an American festival we all believe that
nothing hold on isn't it the day
gentleman by the name of hey-zeus has
just Christ Christie birthday I mean
that real cuz the record books say it's
not okay can I change even if you
believe in Jesus Christ he was not born
on Christmas it may I ask you a question
yeah sure yeah please do it now blot be
careful no no I believe in Christmas
believe in sin I I just want to know
celebrate ro I guess what I'm just what
I'm hearing is that so
do you enjoy putting your finger over a
match let me start there like if I have
a lit match
do you enjoy putting your finger and
holding it in the match or just a bother
you don't like that no okay not because
that would hurt your finger yeah now
would you what if your whole body was
held over a large fire who does a pig
roast yeah now how would you like that I
mean probably I hope I Drive right yeah
and then plus fire on your body on your
skin good skin and Fire doesn't go well
I get tan right now I'm and you probably
wouldn't like that forever Loreen you're
kept alive I don't know where you'd go
with this problem what I'm going with
this do you want to go to hell or do you
want to recant what you just [ __ ]
said cuz he's gonna hear this podcast
well well I believe that a Jen
whoo-hoo flies over Vietnam because
they're non-believers and skips over
yeah he's gonna hear this and I'm just
saying that that I don't wanna I don't
want to roast in a fire for a time I
don't need a little rope but my words
I'm concerned Jesus is born on Christmas
Day and I will [ __ ] I will keep my
chimney open bro all the long-legged
white son of a [ __ ] named Schoeneck
that's a whole nother but my thing is is
it if you look at the record books he
was not born on Christmas it's a made-up
[ __ ] holiday bro I have a quite I
celebrate it because I've son now right
I don't know libel answer does not give
a specific date if say for the birth of
hey Suz Christ if saying it lives up in
the north of true birth date of Christ
this is from his people
unknown [ __ ] and then it says no look
into it well I don't know and that's
from the encyclopedia of early
Christianity hmm it also says but we
know one thing [ __ ] not in winter isn't
it isn't it based on the astrological
like when the North Star was just so in
the sky or something isn't that what
they they followed the North Star I
don't know here's the thing I don't know
I'm just saying it's the made-up and I
have so big I feel like if Saint Nick is
from the North Pole
I feel like he should be Inuit bring up
the average Inuit please
I think he should look this way first of
all you're called up now you're going
down a weird road Brian because Rob geez
Sam shouldn't be white either he's not
he's somatic he's no no nope nope nope
the way he's portrayed he looks like
your average Arab or your average
Sephardic Jew from he does not with a
Middle East so even white he's not white
I'm saying right we portray him as a
white man with long hair we sure do with
kind of blondish brown brown shirts [ __ ]
no he was not white it now is real we
know he's not white if he should look
like that gentleman there now there's an
Inuit now one thing about the Inuit you
should know is that they're Gayle
shaders that's a strong face now one
thing you should know about the m2 he
lives on seal basically 100% carnivores
now here's the thing about the Inuit
they have a certain body Constitution
where their hands and their feet don't
get cold
the way here is a nice word the
circulation yeah the circulation is with
polar bears of human beings that's where
they grew up they laugh at the calls
they came they can handle it well do
that guy in the middle there he looks
like my cousin did heat all the seals in
there yeah that's a wide face
now are there bees in Antarctica because
he look swollen um you need you need
well there's a bug on his face he
doesn't give a [ __ ] that's a giant
mosquito shrinking away dude speaking of
Indians and well Native Americans yeah
when I first nation call him first
nation can I see that guy up there and
with the long hair and that guy's cool
looking all right fight him on grand
variation which the Native Americans
they say came originally from Asia due
outs don't you know when I was in
Albuquerque
the lady who picked me up from the
airport to drive to the hotel was Native
American and we're just talking and
she's like I'm from this tribe it's
actually about 30 minutes outside where
we're going and she's talking about and
grab blow probably right I'm not sure
and then she goes you know there's a lot
of tribes out there and she was one of
the originals you can go where they
still live in Adobe's and all this stuff
and then I go white uneducated Brandon
goes oh and teepees and stuff yeah yeah
teepee dingo well nah doesn't go well
she goes oh I will well educator you on
and Native Americans they go you know
sis skill 110 no I won
I went well I learned you know in high
school what everyone learns and you know
about Indians and when when I said in
and she was Native American alright yeah
yeah I'm sorry and then she goes why
could educate I could take you to my
reservation that'd be cool alright you
know what that sounds great so he can
take your left in a [ __ ] fork in my
eye
I want you don't ya just take me take me
the hotel I don't have time for this
take me the hotel is not interested and
take me ya know see I think it go and I
go well you know what someone ask you
something like god I'd be cool man that
doesn't mean yeah take me to your
reservation yeah so he put mud on my
face let's not do that
yeah she went no I can take you anyway
why would you put mud on your face
because she said that's they were to
talk about some mud that they do some
mud mud show you
and the impression that Native Americans
wear dirt on their face no she says I
just want to get this right get this
let's get far show gets cancer though
know where we can hear God's oh no I
donate so you're not interested in
seeing a reservation and seeing the
people that were in she taught me to lie
cuz she goes I go I'm sorry I can't do
it now
she goes what's the only 30 minutes
outside don't want to drive that far
that's a long it's a long way in
fairness when you you're an allegory I
have two shows that night yeah you don't
have time you just don't have your get
your head together doing here but no the
thing is then she goes it's only 30
minutes away I go yeah no I wish I you
get bassy it's Pueblo right there it's
prep I go I get back issues Oh tell me
your shows I go tonight she goes yes
it's only 11 o'clock yeah no doubt no
doubt
7 and 10 no she goes oh I just wanna
make dude quit [ __ ] I obviously don't
want to go don't force me to go to your
goddamn tribe yeah yeah yeah I've read a
couple of books on Native American and
and Steve Bernal is a a bit of a Native
American historian and so we'd be it's
fascinating stuff that not far out there
yeah see I know it's different I think
she was from
yeah the Navajo I want to say damn is
wild but that place stand up good spot
dude saying was it's you know it's set
up for comedy I told him I said you guys
need to rebrand your [ __ ] man because
when I think casino I think shitty
surrounding doesn't sound well it was
designed as a Native American casino yes
okay
Santana yeah brand-new hotel my room was
brought by the best hotel room I've
stayed in as far as when people are
healing up really this [ __ ] dope
suite damn see it's there it's made for
like DJs and clubs because then they
have big time stand up there twice a
month so it's like it's made a huge
dicks it's a stage called the stage I'm
like yeah just need to remarket it in
more comics to come out here and then
and it's like people come from all over
and it's like a party party place I
think when they used to have like
big-time DJs there right then they
switch to stand up
good-looking people are are you looking
at this you know what why did you just
look up I didn't hear what he said
because I went cuz you went you went you
look no no that's it yeah that's the
stage man you're changing it heads you
and I said I said no I had good green
chile that's not what I asked you
great coffee there dude I said are they
are they good-looking a lot of the
people they're good-looking and better
at this because you know it's a simple
question I don't get the question bro
why are you what you saying people are
ugly an Albuquerque I never said that I
asked you I I've been all City Victor I
never had you ever have to be are they
good-looking okay I was in New York last
week did you go are they good I saw the
only show in Albuquerque for two years I
love Albuquerque and you clearly think
that people wear mud on their faces so I
don't know they asked about on my duties
point-blank I thought it was a I thought
it was a I thought it was being around
the bush dude do they want to [ __ ] on my
face I don't know Brian
Ryan she said you want mud I assumed
freakiness Oh mud so I asked the girl do
you want mud on your face yeah I'm not
talking about the dirt on the ground
well a lot of cultures in sunny places
somehow create they create a barrier to
the Sun you're good of a mud mask bro
who's bad that's what I'm thinking you
certain - holy 8u this the pores on your
frayed that's hate it you know you
people will cover their body with mud
because they're bugs yeah but I didn't
know whenever Brandon strange goes do
you want mud on your face yeah I assumed
something sexual a hard pass for this
guy not my style it's him she maybe
she's in the scat
you want some mud on your face as in a
wink wink I got a [ __ ] that's what I
was I ate a bunch of could you talk
about gene chili green chili before and
coffee I went all right oh [ __ ] your
pants oh and then you just asked me if I
want mud I'm no detective bumpin to to
to here together and you want to take me
to your Hut yeah put on quote yep and
I'll show you my chief well we know that
there are people out there that are into
having poo on their face oh yeah I
thought I thought I was giving some sort
of Native American porno as we kept
driving young Native American there's a
much like a mud bath dude do you can buy
mud on your face in it yet fully eight
your skin exfoliate yeah yeah I do that
[ __ ] bro I don't wanna do it that night
um I had [ __ ] to do now you like that
the black and white person up there went
Chaka face Manila face that's why this
one the only black person for God the
only person with white and black paint
on the sea that's
I'm singing I get the other like let's
kill the gringo damn look at that let's
eat the grease a lot of let's turn the
gringo into beef jerky well they're not
cannibals dude you don't know what kind
of people they are you're assuming bro
well who eat which people are you
talking we don't know that's the thing
person ate I don't know what tribe we're
talking about okay well if we're in the
highlands of New Guinea you might want
to be careful cuz you do look delicious
or if you go to Satan Island like that
homeboy did you know about the word of
hey sue well they didn't eat him they
just buried him
no at least they buried him new info
came out they ate his face off I I
haven't read I read it bro CNN I've not
read that happened in Florida though a
guy was on ice or some weird drug and
and then ate a guy's face beat him up
and ate his face how'd you hear about
that of course you didn't I know why I
know about it this girl did meth for the
first time went you know what my eyes
are bothering me she was high oh yes
ripped her eyeballs out blind yes she
said Laura told her to take her eyes out
I don't know if it was meth I feel like
it wasn't meth it was something was it
meth
I feel like meth don't do there's some
kind of a host energetic drug but she
was like you know I don't want my eyes
anymore yeah woman who ripped eyes out
says happier now Wow cuz you can't read
Twitter comments yeah crystal meth on
this one ooh doggy that's meth baby in
crystal form she was in a person or yeah
they found her eyeballs in her hands I
squished him all day they were somehow
still touched my head I took the team it
took a team of police to calm her down
she was airlifted to Greenville Memorial
Hospital trauma unit where doctors
cleaned what was left of her orrible
sockets
well she I just leave the drugs she
ingested was laced with another chemical
causing her to have hallucinations in
which she heard voices telling her to
sacrifice her eyes yeah and she could
make it to heaven what kind of [ __ ]
drugs are you on the day before it
happened which was my birthday I was
getting ready to have her committed just
to get off the streets and away from it
but it was too late she ripped her eyes
out there at lace with another chemical
the drug I don't know how I'm getting
through it but she is giving me strength
it's weird to say but she uh flips me
right now
Wow she says whenever heats run it's
just kind of person she is man she hits
one block keeps going my god yeah that's
not a good thing drugs no the future is
bright for free you know you're a little
talk this Monday am i dark you I didn't
want to go see a reservation and then
easy bro I celebrate Native Americans I
loved Albuquerque but you suggested that
maybe you'd might get eaten and that
there was mud on people's faces and I
for one I'm already offended and now you
made a joke that she's gonna see the
light right no I said she has a bright
future a bright future right and that is
an outrageous yet funny thing to say now
listen I don't know what's gotten into
you this I don't either I need you to
button it I need I need to take you down
a nut you got to take it down a notch
overall you had a good experience in
Albuquerque New Mexico didn't get webelo
River
didn't go to any reservation look up
what that what that tribe is so we can
educate ourselves but much well there's
so many out there
Wow well while you do that there was
great coffee there some of the best
coffee shops around Lee yeah pinyon bin
honk laughing yo Ben Yong all right and
then I went to a great breakfast spot
dude great food out there and and on
this break as he looks this up I just
want to say that I never did any meth
and things got better okay so say no to
math what were you saying that's true as
anyone done nothing like god I feel so
much better no nobody's done cocaine and
matthan been like you know what I had
problems I did a bunch of meth and
cocaine oh there it is it's a Laguna
pyro said that there you go did you ever
hear about the person who did acid and
then thought she was an orange and
peeled her skin I did not yeah yeah
around the water cooler dude I know I
wanted to ask how crazy would that be to
be so [ __ ] high you're like I'm a
human orange I'm gonna peel my skin
there's a guy my friend said he went to
a party he did a lot of acid and he was
in a bathtub and he started thinking he
was soup and started sucking dick
nope no no he I've heard that before too
though didn't people start cutting
vegetables into their are bastards and
I'm sorry my friend might have been one
of the guys and they started cutting
carrots and I need a gourmet he was like
no
like no he couldn't get away he's not
room maze-like you looked delicious
never cutting vegetables cause he was
haven't had to undress salt yeah Wow
yeah now I was gonna redeem ourselves
it's a it's the Pueblo and they speak
ooh people of the north and Mongolian
culture everyone's trying to move on
from this Native American talk bro okay
they have an agrarian lifestyle and
sophisticated sense of self-governance
thank you and nowhere does it say there
that people wear mud on their face dude
it's all I know is someone mentioned mud
and I get a little scared that's all the
bottom line I appreciate their nation I
respect it okay cash back down all right
I just didn't have time to go there okay
okay I will drop by a lot of other
nations I don't discriminate I'm not
interested in any of them I'm rereading
blood meridian so I'm learning it's all
about what's your yes white devil white
devil we're white Devils dude well
you're not that way you'd be surprised
dude I'm watching uh first of all chin
how proud of me i watch that Kerina I
was surprised in the movie searching
John Cho have you seen it Raja I didn't
get around to watching but based off of
the San Jose area where I'm from oh yeah
that's right talked about it it's
[ __ ] brilliant and it also really
takes play the way it's shot it's from
just a computer screen so it's just him
and cameras that he sets up
it's brilliant the way it was shot it's
so it's all like this him going through
a computer his daughters going to school
and they talked on I chat oh and he has
to find her it's [ __ ] dull how is
that is that guy from Harold and Kumar
yes yeah there you go how is he Korean
yes Korean and something that's the best
movie I've seen in a long ass time it
was so I didn't you know I was going
through it and I was on my Apple TV and
I'm like I need a good movie to watch
and then I clicked on this searching
movie cuz just popped up had a 98% of
Rotten Tomatoes oh god damn that's high
like half [ __ ] it click best choice I've
ever made in my life really not going to
that Native American really good movie
yes it was swirl right there that's the
girl that played the cop yes she was
incompetent
I don't spoil it for anyone some twists
and turns okay cut some twists and turns
I'm excited you say you recommend it
highly highly recommend that and then
I'm also watching that that show on
Showtime called escaping down Dannemora
which is based off the true story have
you notice about this cat it's about
it's a true story
two convicts in prison who were there
they're the real guys stop right there
there's life they skate they escaped and
they escape because they're hooking up
with this female employee at the prison
and they're both [ __ ] go back to that
they're both [ __ ] her they're also
both 6 foot 9 inches tall no inches tall
it's all true straight these aren't a
spoiler alerts it's directed by Ben
Stiller Ben the true story so they're
[ __ ] this employee at the prison and
they basically kind of manipulate her
into bringing them like tools hidden in
meat so they could escape like yeah
we're gonna we're gonna escape to Mexico
pick us up here and to me the three of
us and so she's cheating on her husband
the original plan was they were gonna
get out she was gonna pick him up and
then they were gonna drive to her house
they're gonna murder her husband and
then escape dan they're gonna murder her
husband yeah so there's a girl who's
playing the shark at Rice yeah she's up
for a Golden Globe
can I see she's so good at an original
woman yeah almost you some TIG ol
bitties in it she's all knocked up there
they are it's so good man it's a little
slope and it builds up and you bet it's
[ __ ] good I take it she got caught I
take it she did yeah this didn't get cut
in prison now the other gentlemen
spoiler alert I want to reopen yeah it's
like watching [ __ ] news list like no no
spoil it yeah it's a real thing
yeah Pearl Harbor don't you [ __ ] do
it don't you [ __ ] ruin this realize
like those Avengers like I didn't make
it out then didn't really make it
and I can tell you dude but you see that
this this this scissor this saw that
they used to cut through and he knew
took forever oh yeah
well patience when you got nothing but
time it's a [ __ ] good show man yeah
port risk I saw on Mitchell she was
banging both of them yeah suck him one
off [ __ ] the other oh you know she
was lonely and she hated her husband
yeah you well I think even though what's
other Arquette
she was I don't think she was a bad
person no Rogers lonely and desperate it
got a little weird though when she
wanted to murder her husband that's
where I'm like not a great person though
huh no he loved her yeah well for mother
there he is a couple one two dumbasses
that when you watch us like oh wow we're
not all born equal are we well yeah I
mean people think Connecticut I know
it's at upstate New York that's their
parts of upstate New York that are gray
and there's parts of West Virginia where
like we're from the same race yeah now I
want to be very clear I've offended
everybody on the planet so far where's
Howard he missed it now sound like
you're like a [ __ ] Oh [ __ ]
I don't know so she ate with him I'm not
friends with Brennan look I did the
podcast a couple of times
old-time super dude I'll tell you what
man fan fan voting for guests of the
years getting a frisky
it is a three-man race so in its lumen
Santino D'Elia do Theo Sasso wrap
satellite to sow sow sow his for as far
as one episode where I laughed the
hardest price a so when he it's just how
we do it this is how we do it is how we
do it that was my favorite episode of
the year damn personally my favorite
episode
Santino what have you done for me lately
Santino's representing with the last
last week's episode and thalia don't Lea
cure for me it's a soda leak I know
where the voting's at so I don't want to
tell people I know where the voting that
a little bit so I don't want to but I'll
tell you it that race is a booming dam
between it's a three-man race it's got
to be a three-man race can you say who
the 3dr CEO
deals in it yes love it he's trying to
offend his belt
CEO do
leah and Andrew Santino's those are your
three fronts and it's not even clear
skies aren't even close so I'm just
gonna break hearts now the rest of you
are not even close Wow Wow you know
right well it makes sense it's gonna be
interesting
Santino stepping out of nowhere with the
red hair that [ __ ] Slugger bro the
redhead Slugger yeah coming through
it's coming in I'm impressed don't trust
redheads man don't trust redheads what'd
you guys do this weekend chin what did I
do
fishing we're fishin bro I'm fishing or
fishing again I've been fishing a lot
lately my fishing so much all the rest
just nice to be next to the water by
yourself
nah just me and my buddy who's your
buddy his name's Eric we've never met
him you met at Erik Bryan know what
there do he's white and he's got big
muscles like what tier dudes not white
he's Vietnamese vet from Vietnam Vietnam
name's Eric yeah all right yeah and what
do you wear you guys fishing at we went
to Sunset Beach
Sunset Beach that said it's I know
sunset it's a small eight we've lived in
out you're gonna see it's code for the
gay strip now we're finishing out the
Abby Jensen not the avi uh Sunset Beach
that's that beach and then Bolsa Chica
you guys heard of those boys no it's
closer to Orange County why you fish all
way down there cuz I've done it over
here I've done that like catch anything
from your mouth did you catch anything
plan your place in LA and I'm finished
in LA why LA there's not to ship fish
there's no place to fish okay and I
would catch like fabric
say who caught the fish first yes yeah
no but did you did you catch anything no
I actually caught fish in LA when I was
here but not out there only one fish
here though and where do you know this
guy from um or use a roommate roommate
high school what's he do now he works on
bikes electric bikes you know see where
a tool belt former roommate we're
telling about the harmonies banging new
sneakers in his tool the gay ear a cat I
had a very beautiful lady come up with
her man and she's like listen I love cat
I'm from I'm the same she goes I'm from
Vietnam yeah she goes I'm from Vietnam
she was gorgeous she goes I'm from
Vietnam too she goes I feel like mean
cat would be better on your show
together all right well there's only one
so yeah but a man hot she's smoking and
then she goes what where I'm stuck in
Albuquerque cuz my man's in the military
and we're stuck here like a bull you're
here so I can't get tele should know
we'd go to LA yeah yeah I don't think
the cats holding it down I think that's
good man
I do think of I think Filipinos and
Vietnamese people are very attractive
it's always a sweat in our court yeah um
would you do cat work work work yep
normal stuff just work auditions like
that how are the auditions going pretty
good nothing crazy
no yeah your man's still playing a ton
of video games yeah where do you get
them for Christmas video games uh we
actually don't buy each other gifts
Jesus Christ I don't I don't see boy we
like to go out to eat a lot that's
basically what we do no gifts huh no
gifts smart like I don't want anything
either and I don't think he put off for
your birthday you guess she gifts then
mm-hmm no gifts Pam no cake not here
you're good at gift-giving right I'm the
worst uh depends are you gonna get me
anything for Christmas
yeah dude we've gone over this I'm
getting all those sex doll oh yeah see
and [ __ ] it I would never I would never
that's exactly what you're getting
damn you guys don't celebrate is your
family like that to you grow up that way
I feel like as I got older it kind of
stopped there were so many kids in our
family it's expensive how many
other on my mom's side alone she had she
has seven siblings but my grandma has
sixteen siblings Oh your mama and my
great-grandma is one of two wives so
that's just my mom's I did one of two
why look at me practiced him no it was
like the first wife and the second wife
oh but we're all like one weird family
yeah so he has don't really get together
in holidays
we used to when I was younger I think as
we got older everyone got tired of each
other
spread out yeah we're still all
basically in San Jose though we just
don't really just don't get together
yeah kind of sad yeah it is that
especially you'd like to yeah ginge is
your family get together in Christmas
and [ __ ] holding on my whole family just
my immediate family yeah well my but one
side my aunt what about you be no I'll
be in Africa this I'll be in South Amer
nothing screams Merry Christmas like
Africa nothing screams my think of
Africa I think is like South Africa
Santa Claus Christmas right we don't
think of you and a safari running yeah
naked
well here's the worry about South Africa
right now we're gonna well you get know
South Africa less so different climates
so you're not gonna get the kind of
yellow fever dengue fever kind of stuff
you get there though you know mosquitoes
don't go now when I go into South it's
there it's there it's but very dry
they've had a drought season so that
tends to keep the mosquitoes here's what
you there's what you get here's what
what you don't have here's the other
thing you do have to worry about them
besides bugs we're gonna be on the water
now there are little new rides there
things like that here's the thing I
don't know if you know this well you of
course you don't you know it but you
know that now now in this these months
is is hippopotamus mating season
hippopotamus calving season why call it
hippopotamus you said maybe but you knew
is calving because it was mating I know
you're saying no a tip eponymous calving
season having they have their calves not
saying it's hippopotamus time like this
is one they're out this is when they're
out this one but I knew that I knew you
knew that you know what hippopotamus
they're in season you're passionate
season that's right Robin I said we know
that hippos
are super sweet animals here's the thing
they have a baby that they're protecting
and you're in your canoe and you come
accidentally too close to what mom up
hippo decides is a threat to her baby we
kill you what she'll do is she'll tip
your canoe over and then she'll take you
by the leg and give you a little shaking
oh no should just doubt you with their
giant tongue yeah I'm kill you now
they're the most dangerous animal in the
world here's the thing why in the [ __ ]
are you guys going on the rivers in
Africa well so was a few things I don't
do water giants water Florida yeah
enough drink water Detroit no no sir I
said I said hey listen here's what we're
not gonna do get in small boats and go
around cuz when you fall in that water I
don't know if you know there's another
animal who lives near the hippos then
there's luck with the hippos but they do
[ __ ] with humans so if you're in uh my
leg we got to you're okay uncle croc is
coming up and he's gonna kick your ass
you saw that that hippo chasing the boat
I sure did right yeah so fast it's so
festive members though of their members
of the whole family's going Brian the
whole family is going and yeah of all
the places yeah let's jump on a plane
20-hour flight to Africa but dude I'm
gonna shoot all day on Friday then I'm
gonna get on a plane I'm gonna fly to
New York I'll sleep near the airport and
then I'll get on a plane and go to South
Africa hold then I'm gonna get landing
Joburg and meet my family and then we're
gonna fly to Cape Town so it's gonna be
a fun why why all this well because I
have to go there later I'm gonna miss
the first leg of the Safari in Joburg
that's going to Safari now here's what I
am doing
ready and I think you'll be a little
jealous I'm diving with great whites you
know you're gonna go in the cage great I
got I've always wanted to do that so
we're gonna do that that's one I'm on my
bucket list pretty cool I'm gonna get
one cool grey whites
that'll be cool right that's super cool
GoPro I will take some chances of brine
filming any of this ordinance your c0 I
have the worst oh don't put a GoPro no
why it's the first what are you to ban
find a better GoPro thing right now be
cool
if it's you though I'm not going there
I'm not even I don't care about seeing
the animals cuz I've watched tens of
nature says I'm just there to see tang
with my nephews it might my whole family
that'll be fun my kids I love that my
kids are my nephew's are the best that's
right so far I'm a little nervous going
there with my tiny children dude so yeah
that'd be money and their food their
food and sneakers
dude there's mosquitoes I could eat them
alive yeah you were seeing the
mosquitoes mosquitoes out there you got
dude you know Jay sobs in Tokyo right
now oh yeah you told me that unleashing
that [ __ ] big anaconda eight people
what's he I know he there's a lot there
not a lot of Tokyo gals that can
accommodate I tell you what I ain't just
gonna be one their hands are too small
for him yes well do we have to double up
although I hear guys another night up
they clean up but listen for any normal
white dude goes down there it's just
take one broad if Kirkham yeah for the
other boys it's a it's expensive man
well well he now what's he doing in
Tokyo just him and his foot damn him his
friend Jason the hospital one of his
best friends Jason you don't the BIG's
what'd he do love taste yeah big sweat
yeah we call big sweat head is always
sweating boy tight camp right he was it
so he flew to [ __ ] Thailand and then
he's meeting Jay in Tokyo so yeah he
looks like the letter H just kind of a
big hunt
I was watch that [ __ ] dance and
I was like he's a lot on his feet and I
was like kick your asses he guy like me
kicked my ass like you see him you go oh
you're you're a thick big-headed sweaty
man Jay or bolt into fashion
they're super into fashion now there's a
pan releasing havoc on all those
Japanese people yeah I'd like to go back
there I went there when I was in 21 I'd
be interesting
it was the most incredibly foreign place
it was I didn't know any Japanese so I
finally kid could we do stand-up in
Tokyo
I don't think so you'd have a big expat
military will also x-pac's oh they call
it yeah it's a expatriate but there's a
military people that work there who are
American in their big military base out
there uh yes in Okinawa I believe that's
where we should go
yeah whoever sets that up hit us up
because I could go down there and
[ __ ] of great sushi
yes stand up yeah right off yeah
Tokyo is a Tokyo has always been it says
so Japan has always been influenced by
the fact that there's very few people I
mean very very little land and a lot of
people mm-hmm very little in a lot of
people so so keeping things being very
polite was very important being very
clean that's very important so like when
they have sex isn't like you keep your
voice down
you got a quiet when you [ __ ] unless you
you're taking my my giant dome and then
then you're gonna sing their lineal oh
yeah this is my impression of them every
samurai having sex with a woman and you
yeah you think it's that you think it
fell out she's saying yes oh it sounds
like he's it's a cat I swear to God I
had sex with a Japanese woman when I was
21 I swear on my life I'm not making
this up
and I was and she was gorgeous
and I was I was doing my my 21 year old
thing with my my surprising piece my
skinny body and my surprising pieces
surprised and I swear to god she kissed
she was going and I was like huh let me
see that we got there's nothing like a
Japanese cat with with howitzers she's
got some [ __ ] howitzers on her hey
how about I forgot this when we're in
New York Buster you know Buster's with
us uh-huh
and we get in this uber and this is
black guy from Queens he's like well
it's not mother [ __ ] he's like joking
with us and these girls walk by and
there's like a big like Hospital
transgender girl he's like damn like he
goes oh hell no that's a [ __ ] dude
that's a dude and he goes you guys into
that [ __ ] and was like no not our thing
man no and everything is what are you
into and Buster goes I like Asian women
with big ass he goes [ __ ] that a unicorn
that's a unicorn [ __ ] very real
the [ __ ] agent
yes I don't know we ain't never gonna
see that we were laughing so hard
that's but now but now it's a trend with
Moody's done I think that one right
there let me see what's going on make
sure everything's all right skinny not
that skinny
chin saw oh no tip oh oh no Adam's apple
a dick Oh gross boys oh let's cut it
kind of it's oh oh wait let's talk a
little bit about the fights oh [ __ ] yeah
man ah would you think I'd see you on a
and Jen Jack Valentin chef Schenker and
Jen check was unique in that it was that
they're so highly technical it's so good
they're so [ __ ] good they're do you
think I'm gonna make a statement tell me
true or false I believe that you're on
engendering and longitude shevchenko are
technically as good as any man fighting
a stand-up yzn wise even wrestling even
their clinch game pretty emit a really
calm down calm down calm down okay move
on to another fight calm down but but no
yeah no they're just as good as John
Jones in DC well no no no no no but
they're just as khabib Kevin - no no no
but they're just as good as Tony
Ferguson
okay no no they're just absolutely no no
they're just as coal becoming truck came
no no no they're just as skilled as been
asked maybe I misspoke
all right back to stand up the other
stand up you dude stay in your lane what
do ya good stand up hmm I love that
fight and I loved it are they both from
Poland his Valentina Shivshankar from
Poland huh no I don't think so
she's like Russian or something she is
yeah love her no Janos never in that
fight she had dominated yeah all five
rounds well yeah it was a much of a
fight yeah she she high levels mixed
martial arts for sure Ben yeah but not
much of a fight Kyrgyzstan iam Peruvian
oh [ __ ] dude have you seen her sister
who's in the UFC now no dye me dying let
me let me see yeah I should start
talking that uh I like you out any and
Jenn Jack with a little weight on her
that's great
Johanna lost three other last for its
can get salty out there for stuff man
yeah yeah that's her click click on this
picture see the images for god sakes Jim
come on dude
oh stop hey don't be mad at that world
champion by the way Brian will kick you
in the nuts going on and suck y'all can
you keep going
are you joking me I'm not joking dude I
knew that was your style what the [ __ ]
is going on here no dude elias's you
were like um bo I know you'd like be
right in between I I want to help them
out with some stuff I want to give it
they don't even know this country
they're lost yeah I'd like to be their
guy great other genetics yeah she's
hotter in the ring Carter coach there
coach don't take that don't do your hair
like you're a doo-wop girl don't do that
yeah she got more Peruvian are they
blood related or is there something
going on here they might not be entirely
blood you know what they don't look like
each other do they know she's hot on the
right though am i right I'm very happy
with both I appreciate I'm more more on
the right some ice yeah I mean I don't
like what she does are here though like
that say that right now girls and I
guess their coaches is just a genius
he's been doing some good stuff with
them Wow
what do you think Ortega and Holloway I
loved it I thought this the stoppage was
very important and very good because I
want to see Brian Ortega continue to
fight and the worry that I have is when
somebody takes that kind of punishment
it can really gauge what a real kink in
your career and stop your career and I
hate that [ __ ] I was some people wrote
earlier some people do what stops early
it should have been in fact if you I
think in bottom boxing match it probably
would have been but then again then
again well it's up to the coaches right
the corner yes or take us so tough still
given back still innovating still
thinking he's such a great fighter and
frankly he's the second best fighter in
that division
max Holloway is is just just too good
he's just too [ __ ] good is it clinic
I mean he is he's just so [ __ ]
amazing
I you know born to fight made for made
to be a champion made to be right there
it sounds like Halloween go to 55 now
Dana wants I'm at 55 there's really not
left format I think it's a great idea
too and I think that that that way cuz
must be a [ __ ] both of them both
of them yeah because he why not woman
Ortega was that came to our show he
think I asked him I think he was
weighing 180 something like that ago he
looked thick and stand up I like to come
yeah yeah you know anyway I'm glad he's
okay I hope he's okay I hated seeing him
get that kind of punishment got a guy
who's just too [ __ ] good
mm-hm so so max max Holloway would go to
55 then there would be waiting
Connor donna mcgrevey and great less
employee Nate Diaz that's it a million
big name fights that's it that's a wait
smarter fight for them yeah and then by
the way Wow gamer scholars a fun fight
it's a very thin Brusco Bebe's a good
fight
yes Amber's telling Ferguson's a good
for him versus important to fight him
Bruce could be passing him verse Conor
at 55 s fascinating as Connors the last
guy to beat illness yes yes and you know
anybody better be ready for that goddamn
good the 21st and though tourney
Ferguson miss in there I like what he
said any this is my I like what you said
about that why they better be ready for
that no no he said anybody better be
here's my thing max holler as great as
he is God has he got his hands full
god damn is he got his hands full in
what we have [ __ ] Kevin Lee Dustin
Poirier Conor McGregor Tony Ferguson and
copy it's the best division in the sport
that is the history of the sport a
division correct Anthony Pettis
[ __ ] yeah Gate she's sitting there Alex
quince there's no punk Nate Diaz how I
guess although he's a 1700 I have Paul
Felder
I can't believe fell there's only 15 but
I guess I think the top five for the bed
those other guys he would starch but
yeah I think it starts Anthony Pettis
really alright I like wentest that big
boy if he can suck down to 55 but
thought he fought it 170 what's how I
know I couldn't is always fight a fifty
but has he yeah okay Wow
alright good fights though oh you have
some kind of engine yeah we got a few
Wow how about oh this is great this is
your scat yep I love this you see Nick
Cannon No okay break it Oh Kevin Hart
was asked to issue an apology for some
tweets that came out I think in
2009-2010 where he was [ __ ] around
with some of his friends I'm like oh
this is gay that's gay whatever really
light stuff and he apologized for that a
couple years after those tweets were
originally tweeted he searched her and
after people found out that he was
hosting the Oscars they went back found
all those tweets people were outraged
they wanted him to issue an apology for
it again bunch up and he said that he
wasn't gonna apologize for something
that he already apologized for and that
people are just bringing it up trying to
be negative so he stepped down from
hosting and a Canon came out and did the
same thing and found tweets from Amy
Schumer Sarah Silverman and Chelsea
Handler doing the same thing that were
the exact same thing so Chelsea Allen
says this is what a [ __ ] bird looked or
likes when he looks like when he flexes
and then Sarah Silverman who I'm a huge
fan of put don't mean this in a hateful
way but the new bachelorettes a [ __ ]
which is hilarious Amy Schumer put enjoy
Skyfall [ __ ] I'm about to get knee deep
in Helen Hunt so it's like yeah it's
just what are we talking about hang and
you're using that word which can get you
fired and has gotten people fired so you
know what I use this you know what I
don't like this is the left wing eating
its own tail but you know it's so
upsetting you know I don't like about it
is Kevin Hart does not [ __ ] I'm not
doing it but then apologized like yous
like now I'm not [ __ ] doing it I'm
not gonna give you guys an apology but
then continue to Paul apologized that
yeah I thought that was weird stick to
your guns and just tell them to tell
those tell the 2% or the 1% of these
[ __ ] loud idiots to go [ __ ]
themselves I'm tired of these these
fanatics on the left and these fanatics
in the right controlling how the rest of
us think like it's just to Joe everybody
calm the [ __ ] down
it's not the end of the world Kevin was
also upset because he said that the same
energy that people put into trying to
find those old tweets they could have
put the same energy in finding his
original apology because he
apologize for this look at this dumbass
scroll up this dumbass Adam be very but
after seeing this tweet I did a search
for every time Kevin Hart tweeted [ __ ] or
homo or gay it was a lot and he seems to
have basically stopped tweeting those
words after 2011 you mean seven years
ago he stopped at him bTW I don't care
the year his first stand-up movie became
a hit he stopped using these what a
bunch of [ __ ] who's Adam v-very who
cares no one in look at holla no one in
the world wants to suck that guy's dick
man or woman he's a film look at him
he's a built film reporter for BuzzFeed
news of course think about that his lie
in my spare time I yeah I and cupcake
job is to [ __ ] bring down gentlemen or
ladies who are so much more talented
than you he's a journalist so that's
kind of his [ __ ] is his job what I'm
saying that's fine
I look at me at the end of the day end
of the day okay
you guys won Kevin Hart it's not doing
the operator Kevin Hart by the way hold
on the most generous kindness you know
hold on oh okay you guys won he's not
doing Oscars who do you think it's more
beneficial for Kevin Hart doing the
Oscars or the Oscars having Kevin Hart
host the Oscars yeah the Oscars ratings
are like this yeah Kevin Hart everything
he does like this yeah I'd watch it for
Kevin Hart because I love Kevin Hart in
EM so now they're in a pickle because
you guys are such [ __ ] now your
picture you got it some some poor sap
has to host this dying award show he's
also a beautiful but you guys wanna Minh
being but you won because seven years
ago he said the word gay yeah cuz he's a
comic Kevin Kevin Hart doesn't want to
hurt anybody's feelings I'll tell you
that and personally I've seen with my
own [ __ ] eyes that guy in we're in
Montreal hanging out I saw that guy the
waitress the harried exhausted waitress
comes in she's trying to do everything I
saw that [ __ ] reach into his
pocket pull out what I think was out of
300 or maybe $400 just quietly with
nobody saw and he goes that's for you
just take it he thank you for all your
work I know you're tired and gave her
that money just and nobody saw it nobody
I accidentally saw it he's as generous
and as kind as it gets I mean a deal on
the cannon
yeah good on the Canada's right and at
the end of the day we're comics
sometimes you say things and I never
either the only thing and I'm sure Kevin
agrees with this narrow
I never made gay jokes because I always
knew that there were there were they
were probably 1% or 2% of my own eyes
that was gay and I just didn't hurt
their feelings and I think a lot of us
feel that way but it would no I think
people make gay jokes and it's not right
exactly that's what I'm saying you can
still make gay jokes sometimes and it's
not an anti-gay thing you're just you
know what if I'd come out Ricky Gervais
Street up bets he said the only time I'm
ever offended by comic is when they
apologize for a tweet or when they
apologize for a double down that's
ridiculous a couple now but the Oscars
[ __ ] up here okay reporters Wow you
guys won now Kevin Hart's not doing your
stupid award show yeah
like that that was your objective he's
still worth hundreds of millions of
dollars when so when you get him off
Oscars he's in Australia and a sold-out
tour
flying private back one all right that's
one less thing after worry about gray
you guys won oh no I don't even tape
another [ __ ] movie and get 40 million
you guys won
you [ __ ] dorks and also we rut we get
robbed of the great Kevin Hart making
the Oscars better then they need all the
help they can get those award shows are
dying yeah there's a political but then
they're also just boring so then you
have a Kevin Hart who's brilliant hosted
wow I would tune in for that guess what
no not tuning now can I see what was
nominated for our Golden Globe in the
movies because it's somebody told me
this super political - it's not even
about the best movie the most
politically correct but I I think count
or cap might have mentioned this before
we were talking about this I still have
yet to see crazy rich Asians I heard
very good things about it here you
that's like a black guy and I seen black
panther I just I don't have the time no
no I don't care I don't care about Asian
issues that's what it is cuz you're a
dream being but the film was nominated
for Best Picture and Constance Wu was
nominated for Best Actress in a comedy
and chin and I were talking about
how we've never seen a rom-com do very
well and very lover it's supposedly like
the one of the better rom-coms that's
come out in a long time but I don't know
if a rom-com is good enough to get Best
Picture no [ __ ] no but they're doing it
because it's based off of like store at
school though I think what happens is
you're telling me you don't your honor
I'm sure crazy rich Asians is fantastic
you're telling me that's a better
performance than the [ __ ] dude who
played Freddie Mercury in Bohemian
Rhapsody also great was amazing although
in fairness he's also of East Indian
descent so you know so the guy who
played Freddie murder I volunteer I
don't care white black Asian right no no
whoever the best lose the best performer
exactly exactly
that's what I said okay exactly and I
think and I think that what's happening
is that there's just a need to try to
equalize the playing field and so we're
swinging a little bit over to the far
over here and then with a little ball
work itself out it'll all work itself
out I think at the end of the day you
know it's like they're trying to teach
gender issues in in high schools right
so like what gender pronouns you want to
be buggin and and it's it's hilarious
because a lot of the kids are now making
fun of it like they will if you cram it
down people's throats they're gonna be
like get the [ __ ] out of here you know
there are a lot of statistics that are
not true like women's groups that put
out things like thirty percent you know
that statistic thirty percent of all
women in emergency rooms are there
because of domestic violence wrong but
it's a lie it's more like one percent
how about how about the fact that when
Superbowl you've heard this when Super
Bowl is on domestic violence goes up
women get beaten more that's not true
I'd be downright it's well it's it's
just not true or it's a but it's floated
out as being like a top four dollar
standard and stuff where cuz because
they're cuz your man's team loses then
he beats you that's not true that's a
statistic that's still floated out there
and and NBC in place like that still
make announcements and it's a [ __ ]
stat there's no there's no verification
for that stat hmm they talked to FBI
statistician about rape and like like
one that they say this this dumbass
woman who said one in four women have
suffered raping their lifetime
it's a
that's a complete lie it was flooded up
by a woman thing I think she's in the
University of Arizona and she she was an
anthropologist and she came with some
shoddy study it's a complete [ __ ] lie
but it was brought up it was adopted by
women's groups and it's a good so it's
not even close to that
not even close no no she guys got a cat
for sure see crazy rich Asians though
I'll try to do that this weekend oh ok
so I'm cardi B announced that her and
office' are getting a divorce and
shortly after this woman came out and
made a video of herself crying saying
that she's the reason why party be an
offset are splitting and that she didn't
mean to break up a happy home because
she didn't know how serious their
marriage was come on but I think she
came out with this like stop why did you
make a video of it I had no idea because
she said that she didn't mess with
offset until after before he had a child
so every time after he saw him they
weren't messing around after she knew
that he had a kid which doesn't make
sense then cuz cardi B already forgave
him for cheating the first time so I
think she's only doing this as like
opportunistic for sure she does a lot of
girls just deal with the situation be
like yo look I took cardi B's man or the
reason we getting divorced I feel
ashamed I feel ashamed I don't want to
break up a happy home to to be the cause
so I'm just saying [ __ ] it
alright I'm sorry to think about my
worth as a young lady I just hope she
can overcome this I know her and off set
actually do have love for each other let
me see her see if she's good actress you
know
I kind of read or kind of see I haven't
liked it until today to actually like
get into this seeing everything you know
a lot of girls will just deal with the
situation and just be like yo like I
took cardi B's [ __ ] I'm
reason that they're getting a divorce
are aggressive I feel shame you know
like growing up but oh just come in from
me and like it's a car DP like our
family her fans are gonna destroy her
because we're never mind I never wanted
to break up a happy home cause of
someone just saying like well I mean I
do believe she's mad about it and it's
right shitty cheating you inai elated
online but you know but at least she's
apologizing what else is she supposed to
do you know Justin I bet you by the way
how about this like I'm gonna ask you a
question she's only had a record deal no
no no I was gonna say no no I was gonna
ask you should be in the net would you
would you say Brennan that may be offset
is to question it's a question you think
that maybe off said told her that [ __ ]
was ending anyway at home yeah I don't
know I don't know I wonder if officer
I'm so proud to to to her defense we
didn't know they were married how
serious it was it came out way after the
fact cardi B was like hey we got married
right yeah so people didn't really know
so that's kind of her defensing and I'm
sure offset wasn't saying things are
great well cardi B wasn't either though
like she wasn't public about it so to
her defense and she's delicious
so thank you for a free pass yeah they
actually never really announced their
marriage when they first started dating
no I got married three months in and
then somebody found the marriage license
and that's all you know what I did
because I was in a hotel room all alone
Albuquerque Takashi's kasi secret have
you seen Takashi
I'm in Albuquerque it's freezing I'm all
alone I want to be I don't do well well
the high desert is a is a start anywhere
identify yourself yellow but anywhere by
yourself Brian yeah but the thing is is
uh took Takashi six nine he's in prison
bright going away for a very long time
for extortion and all sorts of [ __ ] have
you seen his girl though who is so hot I
said then she got a six nine tattoo
on her body and dyed her hair the same
way with him they've been dating for I
think about two three weeks before he
three weeks before and for descent
called out there that's her right there
bro what's her name I would go to her
Instagram that's not a fiery girl dirty
girl what I want uh-huh man dimepiece
301 I don't know I look for it so he's
going away for real it's her baby mama
Ayana well he has multiple baby mamas
right now Oh Takashi what is Takashi six
one nine minutes just six nine huh
Takashi six nine that's just his name is
he a great rapper I personally just like
hits now chin do you think that I find
JFK's real killer before you find her I
know you guys I balls are just like
dialed is I'm like no I'm more fair um
I'm more just surprised how bad you are
Takashi six nine has a child yeah yeah
he does he has a daughter all right good
stuff guy wait breed he does make some
[ __ ] hit show and see her yes she's I
just just click on that there you go oh
there she at well so you Jade I'll
underscore oh so oh so you J she in law
school underscore oh so you Jade no you
she's a hard-working stripper Bryant
wait hold on hard-working entertainer
bro I mean she dances yeah okay whew the
night it makes let me see what I'm
working with
no do a honk nap Jim go the one was
shown her ass she's she's a middle one
yeah yes she seems like a go-to when she
goes come see me tonight y'all scroll
down I really looked into this over
Lincoln keeps crawling she's keeps girl
and she'll be in the club key where
where's she gonna be exactly I got Jim
York huh
all right there see the middle one Oh
next to her kid yep that one yeah sure
alright pull up on me at Angel's club
New York okay hey
okay up on me okay Kay yeah she said you
have a problem that Brian you know what
you're too light in the ass for this I
may be but I'd step up let me see
well that's a whole different situation
she's simply a problem
she's a pro like cuz she's [ __ ] one of
the most famous rappers on planet a
problemo
look at her there and now she's make you
risk it all men well now and now what
he's would I Drive my stupid [ __ ] gt3
RS right for that Porsche daughter that
[ __ ] through the ocean for her yeah if
she doesn't read in you can [ __ ] me but
you got to take your car and drive it
into the Pacific Ocean wet your are
gonna be doing this let me see that
middle shot right there this one or this
down yeah right there I mean that's a
that's well that's what as a boy you
know look at the hips on her if that
doesn't make your dick go huh we can't
be friends well you're gay otherwise and
even a gay pan would have sex with you
no I'm saying no that's frustrating what
in God's name is going on now it's tough
house she has pictures of her as a
stripper and then has the kid on there
that's where it gets a little go that
one when she's on the beach with the ass
out God dog diggity dog that's not
Photoshop either y'all that's it that's
a crazy ass she can probably what I look
at that I don't I think of only one
thing
she probably runs super fast does my
squad could be she looks like a great
athlete dude you know what I would do
wouldn't that if I if I was that when
I'm thinking I want her on my volume if
I was with let's say I go to Hawaii
that's where my girl makasian was saying
it away and I pull up to the pool and
I'm with my kids like that right I'd go
to right I'm confused
is this I didn't read the yeah title are
we at [ __ ] Spearmint Rhino right do
you want to change sure because I went
nine to get a boner well here I go hey I
gotta cross the desert and I don't have
I don't have enough to I gotta carry
water I know you store water well in
those two hummus you call it ass in your
camel humps you know I'd say you're
[ __ ] listen you human camel who I'd
love to Bank constantly no but you'd get
you could fall you'd have to strap a 2x4
to your ass cuz you could fall into the
crack of her ass please you don't come
to her without taking your vitamins do
not say come her dumb don't pull up on
her what else what other pictures we got
Jin tan pushing through just cute face
too
she's she's she is impossibly attractive
so it's the sort of Asian but she's
obscenely attractive
she's probably asian and black it's
frustrating how attractive she didn't
combination some would say the best
company oh that's a great agent if you
get some Victorianism
bring it in you preachy so Brit nummies
an African that mix oh did now imagine
that club do you know what you think
you'd like this Brian I just want to run
my feel like we're not her type dude I
don't know what gives me that vibe into
51 year olds with two kids um are you
new to rich white guys yeah can't make
it rain like with your own say I was
gonna say who don't have as much money
as the guys you date yeah what else we
got that's dude there's my girl that's
he I like her like that me too I like
her where she's just leaving Lee and I
are on a boat me too and we've a little
open for my imagination that's all I
need you're just she's just a cutie pie
her hair's all down she's like what this
little old thing little rank little rank
where's twist tasty because I got I got
my I want to see if my my yellow
eggshell shorts shorty shorts look good
can you guys help is your tasty where's
tasty a little thick your twist tastes
your little ring you get a little I'm
little ring ring get a little thick in
here you born the [ __ ] out of me yo yeah
no hey little ring go get a little thick
cuz you bored as [ __ ] little rank now
that you run you risk 24 hours to get it
back up because you're old and you could
give a [ __ ] and you're talking to me
about something intellectual and tell
you little ring you're born the [ __ ] way
me though man kids I like her even more
see I like girls with no makeup who her
backside metal see I like that I prefer
that I don't know I don't like girls
paint their shoes cuz she's naked in
front of me that's naked that's when she
gets naked for daddy you understand
that's morning-after - sure now she saw
us fake I lied
and lipstick but the tone is [ __ ] but I
don't either and her hair is not her
everybody here's the thing I smile like
my women like I like my Christmas girl
ranked first twist tasty ah he's still
sleeping right let's get off of her or I
start jacking off keep going so have you
guys seen the Travis Scott photo I heard
about it what happened a photo came out
of what seemed to be Travis Scott with a
girl and the photo went viral people
were adding kylie jenner saying oh he's
cheating on you and a few hours later
she posted up a photo of her and him
trying to show people like oh this isn't
real or I don't give a [ __ ] and a couple
days later it came out that the same
people who set up the Justin Bieber
eating a burrito sideways photo set this
up too and it was actually a fake photo
what a bunch of weirdos why add that you
think they said let's consummate
problems in his relationship they said
that they wanted to show everyone not to
believe everything that they see on the
internet that was a reasoning sure
they're getting better and better at all
that stuff they can have videos of you
killing some fake stuff yeah Wow
what else we got good for him for
busting that case so Tyler Perry went to
two Walmart's in Georgia and paid off
all of the layaway bills so he yeah he
was able to cover a lot of bills for a
lot of they released for Christmas
that's [ __ ] really cool that that's
that is mm-hmm tis the season
white Howard accused of threatening
Elena all Z and yep we've been over that
dude what else we got what is going on
with that any new things he's out due to
buttocks trouble he's have surgery yeah
I didn't read that what did word word
did where you get it I'm serious he's
missing the season because you have to
have glued its goodies Maximus surgery
okay which one his boyfriend or Dwight
him they don't know if it's real or not
though she is she's known for doing it
what else you got this Princeton
acapella group they were told not to
sing kiss the girl from Little Mermaid
anymore because of
it's sounding too aggressive here says
here some students complain the
performance promotes misogyny and toxic
masculinity do you think maybe has to do
with a bunch of white singers don't want
to sound Jamaican anymore you see good
or you got to kiss the girls if they
have like two random people though like
a guy and a girl and they kind of ask
them if they want to kiss each other
during their performance so I guess
that's the famous sisters oh great this
is a bunch of people virtue signalling
and they go along here's my finding
finding example we get those [ __ ]
this is I've no other word to describe
just a bunch of [ __ ] well I think the
people that are don't want to sing kiss
the girl are the worst know me to the
biggest bunch of [ __ ] more HOD no but
just something I'm looking for thanks
here's the thing not one of them are
successful now people who do this are
not success expressions imply that not
using aggressive physical action secure
aerial sexual submission makes Erik weak
and irrefutable scaredy-cat apply that
masculine is contingent on domination of
women this attitude can catalyze violent
ten have you ever heard that lobster
sing but look at that look can hit it
chin
now let's shove it right up there yeah
stupid [ __ ] faces that's her that was
by the way that's her the one that wrote
it she's a feminist she looks like she's
taking a hundred parties [ __ ] but
doesn't anything about the world so
she's young and I don't look at her jaw
she looks like she take a [ __ ]
dum-dum
not that I would ever hit a woman I'm
just saying she's just a young dum-dum
well young dumb dumb dumb and broad hit
that song this for all you [ __ ] out
there and for sure turn the volume up
dude we've missed half of it alright now
let's do this right
let's sing this for these stupid idiots
I feel like you play there you see her
sitting there across the way she don't
got a lot to say it's a nice song man I
feel like you play a good lobster be if
the lobster bit possible
yeah just kiss her it's called romance
it's called a salt and brother
he's looking to get kissed and he's shy
and this dumb woman missed that point
but she's also 19 look the boys too shy
he's not gonna kiss the girl although
she wants to be kissed though that's the
whole point in the [ __ ] movie I love
when these feminists who are nineteen
years old know nothing about the world
over each you know you know some
feminists will let their daughters watch
Disney well they're they're all they're
being saved by the prayers it's not the
way it goes they're not gonna save up in
you know what a feminist is a woman that
you want to change the world I would
look what valentina Shevchenko and um
Jen Jack do every man out there like
junk chat holy [ __ ] they're like damn
these women can do what men can do
that's that's being a feminist you
[ __ ] phonies all you do is try to
censor the feminists like this try to
censor scold shame and they don't change
anybody's mind or hearts
you wanna inject those bad women why are
they I bet you know those women no any
of those women's names and those were a
deal more women and more of a feminist
than any of those dummies can never be
instead they're censoring Disney and
that's a great song you know what's his
role mass growing here from me Brian I
need you to take it down
sha-la-la-la-la-la kissy dude kiss they
do one and kiss him go and kiss the dude
he's him suck his [ __ ] go ahead and
swallow that card
I'm time to keep things romantic take it
easy
nah nah man I'm the big a lobster I'm
trying to suck your dare is strong and
he's aggressive just look at his mouth
and kiss the boys boy very thick hair
and he's got some heat crooked teeth
with a lot of heat the old man to see
your nah that's crooked teeth and smart
all over his body
put that on
he's got crooked teeth and psoriasis and
it's got lots of wrinkles too shalalala
Castellitto ringing grey ass hair gray
ass has precise the size of a ball it's
gonna die soon so kiss his thin lips
fizzy's thin lips he smells like old
skin
he smells like mothballs going to sleep
man is a dusty moldy old man with the
panicles on his bone shalalalala pay
your bills going into stella man just
hold your nose and close your eyes and
kiss attended someone else in kiss your
hand all right what else we got sorry
all right history has been made here in
the US the first transgender boxer wins
by unanimous decision
okay so I'll hold a hold hold hold hold
34 year-old former Olympic boxing
hopeful not only made professional
fighting debut and beat Hugo so was it a
female-to-male yeah she said that she'd
give me bat mail yeah man 1 and one damn
it's impressive
now now for the feminists if it was a
male who felt like a woman went to
female compete against females we up in
arms but we're celebrating a female well
that's because that females are at a
disadvantage physically with fire bro
we're all the same yeah these feminists
we're all to say bro all the same yeah
okay yeah yeah guy female Navy SEALs you
have a gaijin Juwanna Mann go in fight
boxing let me know how that works out
for everybody
yeah good we're all the same good for
her for [ __ ] competing with the men
and do him well that's impressive
very impressive I don't see the person
that he fought yep this is his record oh
you gotta start somewhere bro yeah okay
now Hugo is probably a little
embarrassed okay right went back to his
[ __ ] country of Mexico and they go
who'd you fight he goes oh oh oh dude
yeah and then they go really let us look
into and go hey Hugo
word on the street is you got beat up by
it he's got [ __ ] x-chromosomes
everywhere yeah a lot of sex acts
promises because they're not macho at
all in Mexico No so basically you might
want to down boy Hugo might not
before you bro that's throwing six I've
been in jujitsu classes we're back in
the day when Japanese fighters would
come in like like in hensel's place in
places like that and Japanese fighters
would come in and they were guesting
they were guests they were rolling they
were usually fighted him maybe some
pride mm and they'd be paired up with a
woman and they wouldn't wrestle whether
they'd bow out maybe I know I saw that
with my own eyes a couple times yeah I
don't say that I used to pass like when
we trained Denver with like Michelle
Waterson like karate hottie I'm so much
bigger yeah and like we get pair up like
I'll probably go with small yeah I'm so
much this like when I get much out of it
now I'm gonna get a raging boner and my
friends who make fun of me
so probably go so now she's so I'm not a
sexist oh I'm just yeah she's but this
guy this guy so this was blatantly like
I don't know oh yeah that's that's their
cultural thing yeah continue on yeah
let's go all right this is our bar stool
I saw this not that long ago but a
little luchador kid and this I guess
they perform like this stuff on the
streets in Mexico yeah they caught this
random actor here don't worry about the
audio Jesus how crazy is that
holy [ __ ] Jesus Chris I'll be strolling
tips these kids
Jesus Christ that's pretty emotionally
that little dude that's cute is fun
little kid that's super T right kid man
hey just to flip scripts here did you
see the [ __ ] uh Cinderella played the
Miami Dolphins did against the Patriots
yesterday did not last play the game
they're down by five points or four
points and they do it like the the
[ __ ] hook and ladder whether you know
you guys it tosses it back to win the
game he runs all the way back touchdown
we see that did you did the RAM the Rams
loss yesterday right loss to the Bears
you caveat there it was freezing yeah it
was freezing cold water whether it's
freezing but to win the Super Bowl
doesn't go through a Tundra because
they're gonna have home-field advantage
so they're either playing in LA or New
Orleans to get their key fine baby
anyway ACOG owes me tough though you
know who else tough [ __ ] Dallas
Cowboys man yeah yeah they're gonna win
the NFC really don't [ __ ] yeah the win
their division video watch this play
right so they're down by five no time
left
watch this
stop it leave this o to win the game
there's grunt ow ski who's back there to
stop the hell mayor oh my god they won
the game the fins beat the Patriots last
second play oh my god how about kiss the
girl oh my god that's a lot of toxic
masculinity in one group guys it's too
much guys is too much male stuff going
too much quick put on wwa yeah Wow great
game nothing that cool wow that's heroic
[ __ ] man
and my [ __ ] Cleveland Browns baby I
told you box they're gonna win more than
six games
damn they just I just won right they
just watch Hugh Jackson's [ __ ] ass out
of the way they just won again
yeah the actors you gotta look at this
[ __ ] that's incredibly you know hard
that is a pull off and the NFL
against the New England [ __ ] Patriots
that's a hook and ladder yeah I know
got appreciate this oh yeah look at the
way look at how he cuts through that
that's it look at that the key here is
Rob Gronkowski's back there cuz
he's there because they thought they're
just gonna throw a Hail Mary and he's so
big and tall can jump he just knocks it
down
so they went oh [ __ ] he's back there
well he can't taxi he was on defense
just for that one play because they
thought there and throw a Hail Mary Wow
[ __ ] yeah football's great right now you
[ __ ] you stupid no it's fun I like
drama even so I like my pinky and from
schools in the Northeast where you know
where they've never met anybody in the
real world and now you've offended you
know just the dude what else guess job
boy alright what else you got did buddy
elbow terminates contract a veteran
rider after child porn conviction
uncovered liar for bloody lblack yeah he
had some crazy number of images right
here yeah 984 still images for value
yeah what they'll fine in seven thousand
six hundred and eighty-nine pictures of
extreme pornography which you know makes
me [ __ ] sick yeah so this guy was
part of bloody album yeah oh my god
yesterday didn't know bloody oboe did
not they fired him immediately when this
came out [ __ ] what a creep yeah there
are anywhere what'd you say I said
they're everywhere people like that
three days judge for leniency citing
purse personal personal relationships
that would be harmed by their
incarceration Kyra corn to the evening
times argued should avoid jail time
because he has to look after his mom so
he lives with his mom we are real winner
on our hands uh uh acknowledging that
serious dangerous crimes in court my
friend obviously can care friend I used
to work in a shop I mean live with your
mother she can't leave her that's my
buddy was a cop was a special carbon he
used to work like he worked with the
teams that would find Chopin ography and
a lot of times the people doing it they
block their faces out right so they they
squiggly line their faces out and they
have guys out there that decode that no
for sure
and then they find your [ __ ] face and
there was one dude it was notorious for
doing this in Thailand and the
Philippines who's an American guy and he
was just you know he did to infants said
you know all kinds of kids and of course
selling this and making a lot of
but he was a real like they like one of
the worst guys and they they finally got
his face tea scrambled and he was a
father with three kids living in a
middle-class house everything else would
go away on business all the time and
Justin even my father gotta believe
there's a special place in hell for
people like that there I think so my
buddy said he didn't even look at the
evidence he'd want able to see the
pictures he wanted his [ __ ] head and
he's not a he's not a [ __ ] he was just
like I don't want to see that [ __ ] I
don't either I could never even you know
I can't you know what that in your head
that there's out that that lost that
that was possible yeah what else and
there are let's move on [ __ ] this guy
Halsey you know like Victoria's Secret
they said that they didn't want any
transgender people do you member this
yeah talked about this yeah they're like
well no it's just for you know our type
of yeah what we prefer which is no
problem that's their obligation lack of
inclusivity yeah so she posted Halsey
posted about that well I don't care
Halsey I love seeing remember she's like
Mark Frank and you also love remember
she's black she's delicious and has a
beautiful voice so I have I have adored
the Victoria Secret Fashion Show since I
was young for this year alongside other
amazing artists and hard-working models
friends supposed to be the best time of
night of my year Jesus however after I
filmed the performance some comments
were made regarding the show that I
simply cannot ignore oh here we go as a
member of the LGBTQ that means she's
down to [ __ ] girls fantastic I have no
tolerance for the lack of inclusivity
especially not one motivated by
stereotype if you're on my page because
you watch my performance tonight please
allow me to instead direct your
attention to Gilson an organization that
offers service aimed at protecting LGBTQ
and youth with respect to these youth
targeted by these comments in a world
where they have been made to feel other
I've made sizable donation their honor
if you are a trans person reading this
and these comments have made you feel a
need or invalid please know that you
have allies we stand in solidarity and
complete total except well it's a well
it's a well put together
statement but I made a sizable donation
in their honor
no good you know what I mean this is
America I love I love it I think she did
the wart show and she did the thing was
like damn this is awesome people like a
[ __ ] they said no trans or anything and
supposed to be part of our community
she's like oh [ __ ] I better do something
I bet you she had a grand old time by
Grandal timing the best try such some
[ __ ] in the back and then now she's got
some [ __ ] in the back there's not a
[ __ ] sucking section from what I know
in the back of Victoria's Secret Show
there's not a there's not a booth where
there's where you can do [ __ ] sucking
usually you're getting your makeup on
god dammit you have ruined this podcast
what is going on on this Monday sir no
you need to learn how to be more
included sir honey Jesus you've used the
c-word a number of times I know you are
anti-feminist you want your wits the
care you're wearing a dentist's earlier
which is a direct insult to me yep this
whole thing you've been you're a walking
insult you're a sitting insult today
today's been tough yeah today's been i'd
like you to apologize like the mars
homage but i'm i'm prickly today your
prickly is [ __ ] i'ma halsy fan man
you're a real [ __ ] today i know you're a
real non-inclusive [ __ ] I was just
thinking about Halsey and like she's
like oh [ __ ] here we go so I would
choose to believe that she didn't go to
[ __ ] sucking booth bro there's hot
chicks everyone is there a counter women
during the women you're like all right
cool but we're in the back suck my tit
I'm whole she's not an invention side
over to I beg you would man I didn't ask
you I don't know anymore
I'm look I'm sorry Halsey look I like
that statement because it's it's it's
what you do as an American so I like the
debate if you're really about that life
though you probably wouldn't perform it
she's a good example of how beautiful
inclusive inclusivity can be shoot hey
she's she gay or she straight bro bye
hold on she's fine watch it no listen
yeah GZ she would have threesomes with
him bro really him her and her well I
mean that's why did guys like Jeezy get
all the girls who is G [ __ ] easy
show me that [ __ ] guy why didn't I
become a rap
horton display more attention in music
school I should focus on my guy dude he
doesn't look that different from me he's
pretty phenomenal man from the Bay Area
white rapper has some I don't say all
the hits but huge hits really I mean
they also pipes down Halsey yeah he wins
I guess [ __ ] off
you win dude great outfits - I saw he's
usually wears all black all the time I'm
a fan
what do I do I got to start I don't have
that hair though dude
no that slicked back to this thing man
dude that's fashion - yeah I know he has
compete with him man it is right yeah
he's a handsome dude and he does well in
a sense some say very well what kind of
money you think he's got in the bank say
between 20 30 mil got true like it was
not worth although those are kind of
yeah [ __ ] says I'm worth 200 grand and
as a picture of you it really annoys me
big time I checked it said don't keep
sending me because they send it to me
let's so I Drive up their network that
says you have 200 grand is a picture of
you nine million nine million well still
good
[ __ ] yeah it's good but I'm just saying
that palsy or Halsey holds he probably
more money than he does gay palsy is by
bro by that's my girl bye everybody says
bye because it's fashionable cuz it know
she does buy because she likes dicks and
tits bro yeah I know every girl that
does I mean it's like come on well no
but I think she's had it she's like
making out with gorgeous girls oh man so
nobody's that she's lived with like
another girl dude
whatever you're a hater man you know
what you are you're insensitive you
[ __ ] come to me yeah you insensitive
cut you bring your male energy in here
my toxic masculinity or that that girl
is she remember Ruby Rose they don't
look very hot there I'll take that right
now be Rose I would take the bowl still
out of my [ __ ] house brave but what
the [ __ ] is going on right now everybody
to look like that they got long necks
and big why you guys lips like that get
the [ __ ] out of my house no you can't
have some of my [ __ ] string cheese
get out of here those girls are strong
and they stand up for what's right
yeah what else he got to meanwhile being
super fashionable the same guy I think
that was it
ooh I mean there's no good look her face
her face narcissus because she's dating
somebody looks exactly like her so she
makes that with herself big deal ah
there's no difference in their faces
they look exactly the same
well I think Halsey is way better
looking
I like Ruby Rose of course she's dating
Ruby Rose cuz it's good for her career
with Heidi
frylock together now bro I met Halsey
was [ __ ] with
Machine Gun Kelly which is all old
another thing I don't want get into
Brian but you know it's all white
rappers it's a fraction so i rappers are
tough pill to swallow
aren't they I think so it's all it's all
attention it's all vanity like I like I
like some she knows I love G easy songs
but white rappers are something about it
they're all they're all vain I just see
vanity on Halsey huh vain she's just oh
yeah the posts about you said something
too right like people are seeing that in
her it's all she's both oh yeah there's
a group of people who don't like Halsey
because she always good because she
always makes it a point to talk about
being biracial bisexual and bipolar yeah
oh that's great the end so it's all the
fashionable things and you're bipolar
what a surprise
I don't give a [ __ ] about her keep
calling I'm just Halsey I know you're
gonna hear this still love you babe I
don't agree with any of this hey man and
I will fire Brian right now for you ro
and you know what I'll even kill him
you'd sell me down the river for Halsey
cell I'd kill you down that river kill I
put these two fingers in your stupid old
nose and then shut your mouth like this
and just watch you ah kick him while I'm
singing in Halsey that's it you'd say
that's not Halsey oh [ __ ] oh my god you
don't even know her songs you phony son
of a [ __ ] ro give me one song sing one
song one the Halsey saw one so uh I'm
gonna give you five seconds
[ __ ] yo the shells out here with the
chain smoker what is it five how'd it go
dad if you get the only [ __ ] I
love her you know her we just sit with
the chain screams oh what a surprise I
could say that - you don't know you know
in the meadow not hard don't sing that
song yeah I know I was testing you no
you weren't
you're not a whole D fan give me the
song name one song I'm gonna give you
ten seconds ten shy it's the
chainsmokers six not chainsmokers closer
you just thought I just saw her go
closer no sir I know that we're like
this I pray for you no she just said
close oh oh yeah because she just told
him the chainsmokers closer no you know
the Halsey song she has some [ __ ] hit
me I don't care bro
I'm not part of the fan club all right
but I do celebrate it I don't like her
how about that I just decided she sucks
you know I've decided your piece-of-shit
five years nobody'll know her name there
are steps you broke Lucy you think those
are her white wrapper friend that's 30%
oh no that's 30% and you were turning
red now if you say one more thing about
Halsey and jay-z uh my job snow I just
came to you're white Walker
dude you just stuck your fingers in my
[ __ ] neck that was 30% I could've
just peeled your thumbs off how was she
could dude I feel better about myself I
kind of just got oh what's a heavy it's
a heavy crown no I could kill you you
know I'm saying like it's kind of you
reckon you could kill me with just your
two hands like that oh yeah you know I
don't know it's a it's a heavy it's a
lot of weight to carry around so I know
for an argument and I just don't know
you mind I'm like [ __ ] it I could kill
you
no cuz I would have just thrown my in it
weird so if you're losing your you just
gotta like [ __ ] it and kill you like
fine are you like a man I think this
like cool
dad and dad and liked a lot of weight is
on my shoulders thing not killing you
something really yeah I haven't we
talked [ __ ] about Halsey I'm gonna carry
an aisle around here bro my carry small
knife and uncie that's I wish you would
because then I wouldn't be like I could
just cuz I could just unzip you yeah
then I feel more threatened awesome
you're like the middle you're on I feels
regret I do this I go and I feel zero
threat really yeah at all times for me
dude I'll carry a [ __ ] please diri
like I would respect you more you know I
opened you up I wish you would carry a
knife dude now I I want you to apologize
to Halsey before we do it and I don't
care if you kill me cuz I'm gonna stand
by my principles you know I'd like that
if you come at me again I'm gonna meet
you halfway here meet me in the middle
[Laughter]
I'm gonna pick up my kids alright guys
you should pick these nuts up in your
mouth [ __ ] you bro ah speaking of
picking nuts up in your mouth I'm at the
ice house in Pasadena
oh she's number 28 to 29 while Bryan's
playing grab-ass with hippos in Africa
I'll be at the ice house working [ __ ]
December 28th 29th after that I'm in
Canada Edmonton Canada first time in
Canada in Edmonton I've been to kill
obviously January January 10th through
the 12th and then the grand hago so
January 19th to chose one hour special
Bryan will be there other friends will
be there San Diego Jr 19th get tickets
now keep at kake.com Hays out it man you
wanna hang out some other LGBTQ QRS
community people do you know what LGBT
stands for lesbian bi gay trans no [ __ ]
bro 35 no as I always like I always hear
you under your breath girl I don't like
anybody you know a big deep BD e stands
for yeah big ticketing that's what we
got
big dick Energy bigger than Randy
Couture I want to congratulate you on
having a bigger dick than I'm not
celebrating that why not cuz that's
Captain America's got everything else on
us
come on bro that was guys this has been
a I hope you enjoyed this Monday and I
hope we don't ruin your I hope we don't
ruin your afternoon by looking up ranked
or jacket on or not look him up no do
cuz it made my day I know it was good I
said I'm bigger fine you know it's
nothing any of us haven't done so hey
good good on you Randy god bless and
that girl look like she don't know your
[ __ ] Missy girl yeah she was hot
alright we're out here this is a fine
kid we're out